these are the hands of an artist a man
whose work is so detailed and so precise
you'd think it's real and that's the
point because Robert Baron's art
imitates life that looks like skin
doesn't it I mastered the technique
making silicone look like skin
from his small lab near Washington DC
Robert Kraft's Prosthetics that are so
realistic injuries and genetic
deformities become invisible
for Robert's patience it's life-changing
[Music]
Butler traveled here from West Virginia
cancer took his ear and much of the
surrounding tissue from his neck and
face
today he's getting the first fitting of
the complex silicone prosthetic Robert
has been crafting putting the field on
there it's light very light yeah I don't
know what to say it just well I've been
wait a long time
foreign
the results are stunning
I've got better with it but I still
you know it's hard to be around people
sometimes yeah
but this is just the beginning Robert
will now spend hours doing what no one
else can tinting the ear and skin flap
in meticulous detail so that it
perfectly Blends in with Steve's skin
tomorrow Steve will see and wear his
finished prosthetic for the very first
time
it's a great psychological benefit in
their mental physical and social
well-beings when I get up in the morning
I know when I go to work I'm gonna I'm
gonna make a difference in someone's
life
some artists want fame but Robert is not
a typical Creator he built his
reputation in a place where success
means nobody recognizes your work that's
because he honed his skills as a
real-life Master of Disguise at the CIA
there he learned to replicate the most
intricate details of human anatomy the
complexity Beauty and even flaws
I mean some of those look like photos
that's what it realism there's the word
as a child Robert had a hidden talent
his early art could easily be mistaken
for photography
when I had a coloring book okay with my
Crayolas and everything if I got out of
line I'd take that page and rip it out
of there and start all over in 1963
Robert joined the Marines later he took
a job at the Pentagon as art director
for military magazines where reality set
him on a different course
tired of the daily two-mile Trek from
his car to the office Robert decided to
use his skills to sneak into a better
parking spot at one of the most heavily
guarded buildings in the world you're
forging parking permits at the Pentagon
yeah
now what is that huh
that's a federal offense forging
government property is a federal offense
the forgery was so good no one noticed
for more than a year
instead of punishment Robert was handed
an opportunity a chance to work for the
CIA as a senior forger not long after
Robert found himself immersed in the
shadowy world of international espionage
that's where he got a taste for working
with disguisers and eventually developed
a full face silicone masks that were
flawless
we found out that we just weren't
getting enough information with beards
and mustaches and you know the disguises
had to pass the closest scrutiny like
6 to 12 inches
and if they didn't then their life would
be in jeopardy
Robert's work allowed American
operatives to completely change their
appearance even their ethnicity in an
instance
they could put it on in three seconds
three seconds and take it off in three
seconds a complete face yes
absolutely that sounds like something
out of Mission Impossible
how about Mission possible
[Laughter]
what were those missions well they're
classified so Robert can't reveal
anything more than that they were
successful
there were times where I had to disguise
myself
so who I was disguising would know
uh who I was in the effort to craft the
perfect disguise he met with Hollywood's
top makeup artists like John Chambers of
Planet of the Apes Fame but found he was
already years ahead of their techniques
later he studied under biomedical
sculptors who exposed him to the reality
of a hidden world a world of people who
were tragically disfigured just like the
spies these people wanted to move
through life without attracting
attention
suddenly Robert had a plan for life
after the CIA and the light went on and
I said to myself if you can put people
in hiding
you can bring people out of hiding
or if you can change somebody's identity
you can give that identity back
to these disfigured people
more than a thousand people have found
their way here because they have nowhere
else to turn like the woman from
Pakistan whose jealous husband a barber
took his straight razor to her face
I mean there's more than 12 that I have
that have contemplated suicide
and they're still here
for what I've done for
them okay John
John Hill traveled here from Milwaukee
for two new years to hide a genetic
abnormality called micro shock
there are stacks of photo albums showing
the before and the after eyes cancers
trauma
and when Steve Butler returned for his
next appointment he explained he was
hoping to get back what cancer had so
cruelly taken away just being around
your family and
church friends and stuff it's going to
change my life
Robert made a few final touches and then
it was Steve's turn to take a look in
the mirror
[Music]
it's incredible
unbelievable
just like it did before
great job brother
great job thanks
you're amazing actually how does that
make you feel when you look back on your
life in your career
It's Not Over
[Laughter]
at age 80 Robert has no plans to retire
his life-changing Talent is in such high
demand that he's booked months in
advance
Ramona his partner in life and business
Works alongside him talking each patient
through their journey into Robert's
Miracle hands
how many people in the world do you
think can do what you do
[Music]
I'm not going to Pat myself on the back
but there's nobody out there
that know my techniques
just like his days at the CIA Roberts
still holds his work to the same
exacting standard it has to be good
enough for his own face
would I wear that ear would I wear that
nose
would I wear the orbital with ocular
if I don't like it I'm going to do it
over again
[Music]
see so that's the way I am
and that's the way I'm going to still be
until I drop
after a career devoted to remarkable
Artistry he knows someone's life depends
on his next invisible masterpiece